if you're looking forward to the final
fantasy 12 remake I've got good news for
you it's just a few months away I'm Tony
and this is your fantastical gamespot
news update final fantasy 12 hit ps2
back in two thousand six and the remake
titled the zodiac age is coming
exclusively to ps4 on July 11 note that
this date is for north america and
europe and australia date hasn't been
confirmed just yet if you pick up the
remake you'll be treated to better
looking backgrounds and character models
surround sound support and the option to
choose between japanese or american
voices and the original soundtrack or an
updated version those definitely sound
like improvements for reference the last
final fantasy game was 15 which we gave
an 8 out of 10 over at gamespot you can
also expect a review of the zodiac age
when it launches this summer so are you
picking up the remake are there any
other final fantasy games you think
deserve a new coat of paint let me know
in the comments or on twitter at
chain-gun pope and for all the latest on
Final Fantasy you're already in the
right place
you